دفعت فديه عشرين الف يورو للقوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه لاستعاده حصان اخيرا الزعيم
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف يستعيد حصانه زازو
المفضل مقابل فديه وصفها بانها مجرد بن
سات القصه بدات عندما تمت سرقه حصان
الزعيم من اسطبل في قريه غربل تشيك حيث
اتهم قاديروف الشرطه التشيكيه بالتواطؤ مع
القوات الاوكرانيه لسرقته الحصان عمره 16
عاما وهو من سلاله اصيله تبلغ قيمته نحو
20 الف دولار ظل حابيسكي منذ عام 2014 حيث
كان ضحيه للعقوبات الاقتصاديه التي فرضها
الاتحاد الاوروبي على قدروف بعد ضم شبه
جزيره القرم الاوكرانيه لروسيا وهي خطوه
اثارت غضب قادروف حتى انه قال حينها في
شيشان يمكنك ترك سيارتك مفتوحه ليلا ولن
يحصل شيء في حين يمكنك سرقه حصان من اسطبل
خاص
[موسيقى]